president biden and democrats face a big
test in just over a week when virginia
voters will choose between former
governor terry mcauliffe and businessman
glenn younkin in a closely watched
governor's race
one recent poll shows the contest is
extremely close with the candidates
running truly neck and neck
in last year's presidential election mr
biden won the state by 10 percentage
points pretty good margin there ed
o'keefe spoke with both candidates and
is in northern virginia for us this
morning ed good morning good morning
tony this is arguably the biggest
political contest of the year and what
happens here in virginia is often much
more influenced by national politics
than other states in part because
usually this state rejects the party
that won the white house the year before
as you said the president won big here
last year but our most recent poll of
virginia voters finds likely voters more
disapprove of how the president's doing
than approve
vice president kamala harris campaigning
last night for terry mcauliffe giving a
statewide race even more national
attention i want this man to be elected
the next governor of the commonwealth of
virginia
she's just the latest big-name democrat
to campaign for mcauliffe in an effort
to motivate democratic voters as the
party's agenda stalls
are you in a tight race because of
what's going on in washington with the
president and congressional democrats
listen
i think this election is about what's
happening here in virginia i do think ed
in fairness people want to see action up
in washington while virginia's voted
democratic in recent presidential
elections president biden's big win last
year came with a divisive name on the
ballot
mcauliffe's trying something many other
democrats are expected to do in
elections next year linking his opponent
to former president trump
glenn younkin is not a reasonable
republican
he is a trump acolyte would it be
helpful if former president trump came
to campaign for you nobody's coming to
campaign with me trump has endorsed
junken but to stay competitive with the
closing stretch the candidate is keeping
his distance but i am campaigning for me
not like my opponent
who is bringing anybody he can into
virginia because he knows that his
campaign is sinking and he's found
traction by emphasizing something else
we will teach history but i will ban
critical race theory
junkins keeping his focus on parental
involvement in education and
controversial concepts like critical
race theory
no wonder terry wants parents out of it
and he wants to insert government
between parents and their children that
focus resonates with voters like juliet
schweiter enough is enough it's time
that parents take it back take control
back of their schools
mcauliffe dismissed the issue as made up
critical race theory has never been
taught in virginia this is a racist dog
whistle will it be in the future no
some of the voters we spoke with had a
hard time defining what exactly is
critical race theory seems it means
different things to republican voters
than those on the left but it is helping
the republican glenn juncken which is
part of the reason why terry mcauliffe
is bringing out the big guns former
president barack obama will campaign for
him saturday in richmond and the
president and first lady are expected on
this side of the potomac river again
next week tony
democrats want to hold on to what they
can uh ed while we're on the topic of
president biden and the future for the
democrats his agenda is on the line in
these weeks ahead and he made some
headlines at a town hall in baltimore
last night about what he might be
willing to do what did we learn
that's right he made a bunch of
headlines last night saying that he
believes a deal is closer than ever on
his social spending plan but also went
into great detail about the ongoing
negotiations especially with those
moderate senators joe manchin and
kirsten cinema saying that he takes
issue with the president's climate
change proposals she has issues with
potential tax hikes and that's what's
slowing down the talks
he also went further than he's gone ever
before on the senate's infamous
filibuster saying he'd be open to doing
away with it in order to get new voting
rights legislation passed and on foreign
policy mr biden said the u.s would
defend taiwan if china were to attack
the island but the white house had to
walk that back saying that while the u.s
has a defense agreement with taiwan
there has been no formal change in
policy tony
yeah the president saying certain things
are sacred and that's why he would
consider filibuster reform ed thank you
very much